welcome back happy New Year to us all
faculty students friends speakers
tonight's speaker is Rafael behrman the
edward p bass distinguished visiting
architecture fellow the bass fellowship
was made possible by a generous gift of
endowment from Ed bath a 1968 graduate
of Yale College and a member of the
class of 1972 in the Yale School of
Architecture and bass plays an important
role in the governance of this
university he was a member of the Yale
cooperation from 2001 to 2013 serving as
senior fellow from 2011 to 2013 his wise
counsel continues to be valued
especially as the university addresses
stewardship responsibilities for its
extraordinary collection of architecture
while simultaneously moving forward with
new buildings since his graduation from
Yale ed bass has concentrated his
professional life on to pre-eminently
important issues the environment and the
urban condition his work as an
environmentalist extends from his
founding of the biosphere experiment in
oracle arizona in 1991 to his catalyzing
role in the transformation of Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies into a preeminent force for
research and advocacy as a developer
mrs. Bassin sandbanks square was
responsible for the revitalization of
the once moribund core of Fort Worth
Texas transforming a collection of
derelict historic buildings into a
lively entertainment destination and
subsequently adding and attracting new
construction including skyscraping
office towers large-scale apartment
houses and important cultural facilities
the bass fellowship enables the school
to pair a leading developer with
resident or visiting faculty offering an
advanced to do such pairings make
within the school the kind of
interchange between sophisticated
architects and sophisticated market
based clients that characterizes much of
the best work being done in the field
today Gerald Hines was the first bass
fellow in 2005 teaching alongside Stefan
vanish past studios of also United the
developers of Stewart Lipton of London
with richard rodgers and chris wise
Katherine Farley senior managing
director Tishman Speyer was teamed with
Deborah Burke Vincent low of Hong Kong
with the late Paul caps Jamie von
klemperer and forth Bagley fourth being
a graduate of our school and Yale
College recent graduate of the firm kpf
douglas durst with bjerke Engels founder
and Thomas christophersen partner of the
Copenhagen and New York firm big were
also a bass pair as was Alec Isaac's
Calais art of netherlands-based ma be
development with Alex Garvin and Kevin
gray of our faculty in fall 2013 the
bass studio was led by the developer
John Spence with sarin and visiting
professors Patrick Bell you founder of
the environmental consultancy at Philly
a 10 and Andy buh a senior partner of
lord norman foster's office in london
each of the bath studios has been
documented in a publication beginning
with poetry property in place published
in 2006 and most recent recently
rethinking trunking mixed-use and super
dense documenting the low k PF studio
this spring let us spring 2015 the bass
book series continues with a review of
the work in the studio led by Isaac
Alice park and again in full 2015 with a
book reviewing the work in the studio
led by John Spence Patrick Bell you and
Andy buh this terms bass professor
Raphael Berman is teamed with associate
professor adjunct Sunil ball bolt after
studying economics
at the Hebrew University of Jerusalem
Raphael behrman in 1979 founded with his
father Aaron pearman bjurman sa a
private real estate company in his
native South paulo brazil since the
founding of behrman sa secede day on a
name for the those who you want to know
mr. Behrman has developed many real
estate projects but he is best known for
a number of office buildings in Sao
Paulo that have had a significant impact
impact on the market two very important
beer monk projects are now underway the
first is a 50,000 square meter office
building set on a four acre site on the
prestigious forreal EEMA avenue a
project that will also include a public
plaza and a 500-seat black box theater
and introduced to the South Paulo
marketplace North American concepts of
urbanism asset management and place
making mr. biermann's second project
situated in the federal district of
Brasilia accomplished account and
compasses over two billion square feet
16 million square meters that together
with neighboring areas aims to establish
a walkable and sustainable urban
community for more than 400,000 people
in sorry the relatively new city or some
say city of Brasilia I have to say
parenthetically that is a third-year
student in this school Lucio Costa came
to give a lecture his English was a bit
shaky but he was amazing lecture he said
I'm going to show you the new plan of
busy Brasilia we're applying on a
blackboard he drew something that looked
like an airplane and said that's it that
was the lecture for his Yale studio mr.
Behrman is asking students to propose
designs for a key for a portion of this
fascinating and troubling project
tonight's lecture will be followed by a
reception in the arcade
picture gallery where you are all
invited to meet our speaker /
refreshments and to enjoy the exhibition
archaeology of the digital media and
machines now please welcome Raphael
behrman 11th Edward p-bass visiting
fellow as he delivers the lecture
walking from site to city Raphael
thank you to the stern it's a real an
honor and a pleasure to participate in
the Edward bass distinguished visiting
fellowship I'm really enjoying this and
in more than one way early this morning
I call my old Jewish mother she's always
complaining about my about my
deficiencies and all pointing them out
to me and I said mom I got into Yale
what she's little bit deaf and said
mother I can explain further you know
how expensive these international calls
are goodbye so really I'm glad to be
here before anything I have to ask your
forgiveness for my broken English and
terrible accent or the reverse as you
wish I hope to be able to communicate
some ideas that my that and then maybe
they will make sense to you before
judging me too harshly understand that
beam from Brazil is like being from a
different planet take the furnaces take
the weather this is how you are here
almost today and this is ozzie Brazil
but that not only summer this is winter
so it's anyway you know Brazil we always
compare ourselves United States why
can't we be as as them why they are more
richer than us why we are lagging so
much behind the discussion goes on and
on we have so many shortcomings in
infrastructure institutions equity
finance not to mention occasion
professionalism a long etc some say we
are the country of the future and some
say will ever be but like the poet once
said it's a mess but we love it let me
point to you some of our strengths in
Brazil we have peaceful borders for the
last
in 40 years an amazing population of 200
million of diverse people with one
language no religion disputes nope
separatists a strong popular culture
with an amazing q zine and an amazing
yeah we like the cuisine right even even
our fruits are great we were also
endowed by hydropower not resources and
we are the food food powerhouse of the
world fantastic country and fantastic
landscape and beaches I'm telling you
all this to contest relies my speech and
it's very personal perspective as a
Brazilian developer let me talk you
about that i've been working in real
estate since 1977 almost 40 years ago
that year my father Aaron the got ill is
sold his bank and decided to get into
real estate he was diagnosed with Lou
Gehrig's disease and I just at 24 years
of kids not knowing anything about real
estate or anything else for that matter
was left in charge I was eager to learn
I was naked eager to learn the trade one
of my many issues was with architects in
Brazil most architectural schools would
never do something like this adverb as
program bringing business people to
interact with the students first first
of all they despised real estate
business only public buildings with a
social agenda would be considered
worthwhile young actors are taught that
clients are obstacles in the way of
great projects I remember back in
nineteen eighty I was starting to
develop my first office building and I
wanted to retain one of the most
knowledge our cadets in San Paulo
giancarwo gasparini I went to his office
and explaining the project he said okay
come back in two weeks i'll have the
design for you I said no no but but I
want to discuss with you I have some
ideas no no come back in two weeks and I
have the design for you said I walk it
out of that celebrated office never to
come back architecture is the sole are
that cannot fulfill itself without the
third party the Arak that needs the
client and not only because of he or she
is the one that said foots the bill but
also sets the parameters the market
reality and the budget and all sort of
the limitations and that's the real
creativity to do design with seen
constraints that's the real deal but the
client does not only set the limitations
sometimes he or she brings visions and
dreams likewise no developer can do or
can achieve his vision without an
architect you see I love architects
sometimes I even envy you but it goes
away very fast
so in my career I focus on office
development not an easy job in those
times of instability hyperinflation I
sky high interest rates in a market
without debt or equity my first office
develop in 1980 was a build-to-suit to
back 10 Dixon headquarters sorry
headquarters in San Paulo less than
4,000 meters after that we built a
succession of look alike buildings for
instance the air to Henderson building
and others today they look pretty simple
buildings but at that time they were
matters to me then we built the Deutsche
Bank building the Deutsche Bank
headquarters in some part in 1990 it was
a breakthrough it started as an
speculative building speculative
development but add all the
specifications of a headquarter building
all clad in granite and all that I know
those projects were good but not great
the more I learned about the more I
learned about buildings the more I
wanted to learn so when in 1990 we got
this terrific site we named it be 21 and
decided to raise the bar the simplest
way to do that was to retain American
architects nobody was doing that octet
architects in Brazil they're very
protective or their turf they say we
have one of the greatest architectural
traditions in the world why we need
forest work here they don't like foreign
architects but they love German cars
they love Scottish with the lot of
French wine
to me the choice was simple local design
was not up to date with the latest
office concepts or technical
specifications they lack at
disappearance the volume while a
brazilian octet at most could have done
a dozen buildings an American film would
have a track record of millions of
meters we came to the US and interview
several firms and end up retaining
Skidmore Owings and Merrill I believe
their backlog was low at the time and
they are glad to get us poor South
American developers pain small fees and
we got us their clients in that project
I work it with TJ got this dinner at
that time TJ I had hair TJ had well head
hair and this is how we look today we
also work it was Mustafa and david
childs david was the chief designer of
the first project it was a terrific
experience David asked me what I wanted
which design alternative I like it I was
delighted with that change in the client
architect relationship and I took much
more home than I could get back there
the building we are doing the building
we were doing had texture had details
had character nuances that no other
building in town had we also retain it
jbn jbean jbn be the new york MP mep
engineering firm and several other
American consultants from different
specializations the American team the
American team was also mirrored by a
Brazilian team and we used to come here
and go back many times and we had
terrific time it was a lot of work with
a lot of fun too
the building was a huge success and set
new standards for office buildings in
San Paulo and after that we did a number
of buildings 30 other exam was som we
did the Santiago Chile building it's a
terrific building also set the standards
there we had a terrific tenants rose as
you can see Microsoft JP Morgan and so
on the terrific building we did the JP
Morgan had quartz in some power very
demanding client and we are happy to be
able to do that building wien more
recently with the day what we call a
speculative building b 31 that's just
next to decide i will be showing you now
the next property within today using
American architects and engineers helped
me to improve my development and for a
while my projects were considered the
most advanced at office buildings of all
I was the most admired every and copy
develop in town I was feeling great
pleased with myself but then those are
the times you have to watch because life
is a cycle and in 1990 my company went
into the restructuring mode not
everything is rose in a developer's path
you see here there's another difference
from between America and Brazil their
banks require full records to the barest
acid every on every lawn very different
from America so when you go under in
Brazil you really go under and that's
very different from America here Donald
Trump can go belly up several times and
land back at Forbes rich business
released every time not in Brazil tough
times but I managed to crawl back some
scars
someone's but still alive and kicking
older poorer but wiser well not at the
merit wisdom sometimes I long for young
average some power back in 2005 I got my
failure Lima project d32 rolling again
two years later 207 I also would acquire
the land of our large urbanization
project in the most significant in the
most significant embodiment of the
modernists it in Brazil if not in the
world Brazilian but first let's talk
about the some pollo project the site is
located in the most prestigious business
addresses on power faria lima avenue
it's a huge site with some 14,000 meters
and an FA are allowing an affair of four
times that comes up to about fifty two
thousand meters of eligible area
and 120 thousand meters of total
construction area that project was a
struggle we had to buy 35 different
properties to fully assembled aside it
took us nine years from 22 1998 22 2007
to complete that side we submit the
plans for approvals in two thousand oh
seven seven years ago and I still don't
have the final approvals god William
someday before I finish the building by
mid seventeen this undoubtedly will
arrive I hope this has been the most
challenging time consuming
nerve-wracking real estate deal I ever
done I'm partly to be blamed for it for
my fixation on making this building not
only a landmark design and a
state-of-the-art technical installation
but also a statement to urban
integration the project was to me an
opportunity to explore the relationship
between the building and the city to
walk from the site to the city as I say
searching a new look to the city and a
new look into some power or Brazil's
urban issues my city is on power as many
others in Brazil are in cows today how I
see this too much government in
conversion and regulations obsolete I
gene concepts ventilation setbacks and
the maximum Farr for produces a sea of
disconnected buildings legal legal
developers were subject to excessive
regulations for urbanization for
organization projects but squatters and
illegal occupations where granted
incentives by the government this
resulted in the verbalization of our
city's good intentions plus
bad ideas always produces terrible and
disastrous results and trigger up the
law of unintended consequences sorry
step we have what I call door to door
urbanism the street the public realm
where people would interconnect interact
become just a passage from one door to
the other the way I see we can trace
many of those issues to the modernism
urbanism the segregation of functions
the low-density Astra wide avenues all
this led to distraction of distances
infrastructure costs and consequential
infrastructure deficiency and this
psycho has led to cities without
mobility where we lost our streets to
the traffic jam we lost our civility we
lost the public space and we lost
urbanity and the most war the worst and
most damaging concept from modernism was
the tabula rasa in our desire to be
modern in our anxiety to reach the
future by shortcuts by cutting loose our
links to our past to our East history we
end up with no cities that was the most
crippling consequence of modernism and
in my personal opinion had liquor boozy
the Saint patron of modernism the power
to get his way Paris and real and many
other cities would be gone for some
modernist obliteration was a
prerequisite to creation the destruction
is part of that legacy of Brazilian
modernism just one instance one example
for you of this approach its own power
in 1900 we had an electrical tramway
system and in 1933 we had a network of
260 kilometers that's almost four times
what we have today in our crowded subway
sneck but in 1935 mayor prestes Maia
decided to he elaborate this plan call
the avenue plans and they have a new
plans was the idea to make lots of new
evidence for a lots lots of new cars in
some power from there from from that
date on it was all the way downhill
until in 1968 when all tramways were
totally decommissioned you know I like
cars they are practical fun to use and
even sometimes can help in your love
life but but Brazilian modernists gave
car too high a priority they went all-in
for that symbol of modernity perhaps we
could call it car architecture or car
kotecha this misguided attraction still
with us today last year our government
was subsidizing cars and gasoline
creating some of the world's worst
traffic jams in Brazil partially
modernism to be blamed one major problem
that I can't play modernists is what i
call the architecture of fear
crime rates are falling all around the
developing world in all big cities not
in Brazil the concern for security has
led to a city of walls fences where
criminals roam free and everyone else
dreams of living in a prison there is a
secondary crime in crime it kills
urbanism public space is destroyed by
fear was still our perspective and
kidnap our mobility back to Burma 32 in
the process of design in that building
we wanted to explore the relationship
between building and city we felt that
our building should be a positive factor
in the city what should we do DD Bay was
there acted did he pay here and we were
putting together the site its
configuration became an L the
configuration became an L shape with a
very long stretch facing faria lima
which is as i told you the most the most
like prestigious address and some power
most developers would simply put the
building face infidel limit the biggest
largest the frontage of the building
Faria Lima but the DNI decided to set
the building in the corner for that we
freed enormous a very large space for a
public space it was an opportunity we
couldn't miss but at the same time there
were some issues because you see this
small stretch here it was a very small
street that existing the side I didn't
need the street to do the building
unless I wanted to free the room 3d
space for the probe the public space
but I decided to go over that that way
and that's what we did although it was a
very nightmarish difficult approval
process as you can imagine but such a
public space would be such a powerful
statement an example in some power that
we need to do it you see all commercial
buildings on fire lima and most of other
business address business locations are
behind fences or walls and even when
they have some open grounds is just
landscape not public space I wanted to
interact with the city the building
should serve not only its tenants but
the community as well what makes a
property valuable it is the contest the
public setting in real estate lingo
that's called location you remember
location location location not only but
that's not location not only add address
but the relation to the urban grid and
the public space they weighed the
building connects to the ground and its
surroundings by the way I have a funny
story about that another funny story the
deep a when we were hiring him send me a
letter saying if I do this building my
design willing improve the value of all
the buildings around and one of my
partners said what crazy architect are
you hiding he is improving the order to
do that the competition value not ours I
said well that's very simple let's do an
ugly building and we decrease everybody
else is very so we went the other way of
course and we hope to be doing a very
beautiful building and that will
increase everybody else value we also
wanted to make the public space truly
functional and we asked Fred can't from
PBS to help us define what was required
we designed the public space with their
help
many of the features features day today
they help us to define their we have we
hired a local young octet Asia hayakawa
to design our 500 seats theater as a
public amenity to be in our public
public space and we hired Tom Bosley the
New York landscape designer Tom Bosley
he designed the public space and when he
was designed the public face he said no
I felt we need to put a sculpture at
this corner to mark the point and cause
attraction to some sort sculpture
pavilion we didn't know what to do but
then later on we came with the ideal do
the sculpture of a whale symbolizing
life sustainability struggle for
survival and not to not forget renewal
the story of Jonah as a renewal and
rebirth and then we did the design of
our whale and it will sit there as a
symbol and we believe it will be a very
profitable for some polo's struggle to
overcome its cows and create any more
remain fluid and dignified urban
environment it's a huge sculpture with
some 20 liters so it will be a big
impact there wait a minute whales and
symbols you main cities what's all this
undeveloped chauvinist blood sucking
profit years
what about the bottom line what about
all our finish our responsibility to
shareholders public space that attracts
strangers and I'm desirable to the
building grounds these are questions I
ask myself every morning when I look in
the mirror but I never got a straight
answer how to answer this what do we do
we're developers stand in society how we
move forward developers get no break in
Brazil we are we have a horrible
reputation real estate speculators it's
estimated fight on us we are considered
slightly better than serial killers but
are we the same as others if you prick
do we not bleed if you tickle us do we
not laugh and if you poison us do we not
die Shakespeare well perhaps however
undeserving that bad reputation is some
change is needed we need to look beyond
beyond the limited marketing
recommendations beyond the bottom line
beyond the site boundaries a piece of
land is more than a financial
opportunity to think only about money is
impoverished I believe these reflections
are relevant for some power and more so
to our project in Brazilian but if we
talk about Brazilian we end up talking
about urban is Brazil irritated and
inevitably about those three Oscar Lima
loser costs in liquid booze iam oops
the influence don't read many near my
had in our country for better or worse
or for bad or worse was huge someday
someone will figure how and why and it
is unreasonable to blame on them to
blame everything on them but they
represent this approach more than anyone
else interesting enough those tree had
an early interaction in another project
at the very beginning of Brazilian
involvement with modern Desmond
architecture the design and construction
of the ministerio de Lucas own building
in real it all happened in 1936 during
the vagus dictatorship his Minister of
Education Gustavo cap anamur wanted to
build a new headquarters for his
ministry in real that at the time was
still Brazil's captain kappa gamma had a
competition to choose the design of the
building a winner was chosen i don't
remember his name nobody remembers his
name because Lucio Costa convinced at
the minister to disregard the
competition winner and give him the
project so much for competitions Lucio
Costa put a team together team of young
architects among them a young intern
named it Oscar Niemeyer they got like
abuja to joined the team liqueur boozy
came to brazil by Zeppelin we had that
at that time while pretending to be
doing a series of conference in Brazil
he was working into the project Nehemiah
Le Corbusier got off from the start and
the young Oscar was the draftsman and
translator of liquor boozy ideas to the
team when the building was completed lay
Corbusier claimant authorship and fees a
big mass in soon but after some
bickering and discussions they all
became
hands again after all all their
involvement with that great master le
corbusier Lucio Costa and near my Oscar
Niemeyer became the deans of modernist
Brazilian architecture I strong
friendship between the two between
Lucien Oscar was established the plot
thickens enters juscelino kubitschek the
mayor of Ballard's aunty capital state
of capital of the state of Minas Gerais
in 1942 he hires near meijer to design a
public building named it from polio the
project becomes welding rinone renewed
in Brazil Oscar becomes very close to
the mayor and the mayor becomes Brazil
new charismatic president in 1956 we
call him jus Selena Kobe Shaq erotic our
JK like your zone JFK JK wanted to take
Brazil to modernity with a snap of his
fingers let's do five years in 50 years
and five was his slogan having some
spare time he also wanted to move the
captive the central brazil he asked his
friends near meijer to design it
nehemiah say is not now thank you i just
want to do all the buildings
now now near meijer has the chance to
repay his old boss and friend he calls
Lucy of course there is a competition
but you already know how competitions
are in Brazil near meijer friends was
chosen to design the capital on his bid
to the competition after claiming he
didn't want to enter 2 enter it he
submits a letter and a few sketches a
dozen sketches he poetically says that
his design follows the idea of a cross
and X marking the spot a gesture of
taking possession I'm always amazed how
some actors seemed confused their art
architecture poetry different things the
talk doesn't match the walk the plan was
totally copied from Le Corbusier urban
ideas he proposes separation of
functions speeding cars crossing
highways no streets no sidewalks
sculptural objects separate by beautiful
lawns clean and deserted no density no
urban interconnected and connectivity no
people people had no room in there they
would only spoil the beautiful and clean
picture but they built Luthor's plan and
most of near meijer buildings and both
achieved the status of God's genius in
Brazil you know not all geniuses are
good some of near meijer project are
beautiful were beautiful take the policy
tamara chill the palazzo do planalto and
they are virada palace but those were
done in 1960 what after
near meijer is often credited with
adding curves to the straight lines of
modernism he famously said it's not this
right angle that attracts me nor the
straight line created by man what
attracts me is the free and sensor
curves of the mountains of my country
the rivers and the body of a woman
beautiful words may be beautiful lines
but what about the user of the space
it's always impossible to use a near my
building they are too hot too cold too
noisy to dry too dark to to impossible
to use human beings were not his concern
furthermore our present JK jataka the
guy missing an F had to build the new
capital in three years in the middle of
nowhere no infrastructure no roads no
power lines they transported cement by
and bricks by plane nobody was ever able
to calculate the cost of building
Brazilian but some consider it the
single most important cause in the IP
inflation we had in the following
decades and no one will figure the
hidden cost to our politics our society
and the end to our nation that that type
of urbanism carried when when I realize
the daunting effort it was to build
Brasilia I asked myself how Brazil had
the energy to focus on and building so
such concepts that nobody else did why
we did it I frankly don't understand by
the way
JK also the biggest promoter of the car
industry in Brazil as those symbol of
our modernity and development finding
how those things still evade us after
more than half a century it's like Al
our logo order and progress we still
don't have it still waiting for that now
maybe what I consider the strangest
think deserving a place in the Ripley's
Believe It or Not show is the scant
criticism in Brazil we have four lucio
Brazilians or near meijer building
criticisms reduce it to a footnote in
relation to the huge glorification that
those two have and those unrevised
uncritical urban ideas have the last and
influence in our country we got stuck in
it we got we could not move forward but
maybe i should add the parenthesis here
I do love modern buildings I'm doing one
that's a modern building my biggest
issue is bourbonnais still maybe I
should say something else in their favor
they were from the early machine time
they would know no better they were
dreaming about the dignified housing the
living machine dignified Taylor Taylor
East cities even wrong ice can
sympathize with their dream of dignified
housing cities I did all that the two
about Brasilia urban problems and
developers bad rep to get to a project
in Brasilia funny enough it all it's all
connected and all it started by chance
back in 2007 a friend asks me if I'll
have you some I have some business in
Brasilia why don't you come with me said
okay I'm not doing anything else let's
go and then I was standing is this huge
open field missing the opportunity to
say something of historical significance
I just mumble this is huge it was really
huge it was really huge with 16 million
meters of land and five million method
meters of sellable real estate it was
big and that day I was there looking at
the site with a very humble desire to
help our cities how tourism filled my
soul I hardly could think about the huge
amount of money that the deal could
bring maybe just a little it crossed my
mind you see it I had an irresistible
vegetable pot were that side as he as if
all had happened not by chance but by
destiny what an opportunity we were
granted right next Brazilian to do all
that as you all know Brasilia was
brazil's idea of moving the capital to
the center in Brazil so there what they
did is that they covered out what he
called federal district a 50,000 actors
area and right in the middle is what we
call planet below to the small portions
were loose Acosta's cross was designed
around the core they built a large green
the idea is to build a green a green
belt and the plan was that the city to
have 500,000 people but today is ready
two and a half million people and pretty
soon we figure it will be 33
half million people they had Lucy causes
a gal Italian plan was that the
government annoyed scatters higher law
Richard poo would work and reside in the
plan appellate as equals it didn't work
because when the workers that came to
build Brasilia and they came from
everywhere from the Zille they all came
to work that was a mecca for work and
they came and when they decided to stay
they had no room in near an elusive
crosses plan they built some favelas and
settlements today but very quickly they
were pushing away to the satellite
cities satellite towns so they couldn't
live inside the planet below today they
had to live elsewhere all those
satellite towns and today they have to
commute by bus one or two hours every
day inside Brasilia there are only about
350,000 people living but during all the
almost all of the jobs are there so they
were driving by bus or pool they go out
in the evening most recently all those
towns have amalgamated resilience
becoming a big conurbation our land is
quite close to Brazilian and also you
can see it's quite big in relation to
the Brasilia it's about the size of one
full portion of the one wing of the
Brazilian here too we thought about
having to look beyond the sides beyond
the boundary of our sites because we are
interconnected with existing populations
so when we do that we design our urban
plans for an overall area stormwater
public transportation sewage everything
we have to think beyond the site we call
this area Colorado sub regime but
interesting thing about Brazilian is
that this already exists is in our site
we have about 30,000 people living in
seven or eight thousand houses living in
our site without title without any
approvals they built as a favela but
they build even eight eight stories
buildings but although they have legally
they would be a favela they are rich
people favela they all have swimming
pools and they are they are aging the
house here I was half a million or more
so before we start with the rest of the
development will be doing what we call
regularization so out of the 16
millimeters we have about 8 million is
already occupied so now our plan now is
to sell each one of those 30,000 people
did the title for their land it's a lot
of smiles there but as a tough tough
work being done by my son Ricardo the
rest is development areas we have eight
millimeters of development areas out of
that eight million will use about five
million for public space between at
three millimeters park and on the three
million that's left we're going to build
about five millimeters it's a huge thing
probably the best the largest urban
development in Brazil and it's not a
person and most people just partner
we're doing a city and we thinking about
the city and to do that we're doing
workshops we call these guys from PPS
Gary hey George wilheim and David seems
from gal and we all working on this play
hands and is these workshops and we come
in with a grid we don't we don't want to
do the same mistakes in the past they
don't want to define too much we don't
leave room this city to grow but you
need the seeds to grow so master plan
approve it well the names are just names
as you know so our plan is very simple
to make a city people we enjoy living on
it our dream is a walkable City with the
streets sidewalks squares full of people
no highways the highway for speeding
vehicles dividing everything but small
streets for slowing cars yielding to
pedestrians public transportation that
dignifies lives six cities not cast in
ideologies but malleable to change not
sterile monuments nor prefabricated
hives of conformity no old to futuristic
machines or nostalgia for fantasize
bucolic rural life no hateful man
disguise it as lower for mankind
sometimes i feel is as what epitomized
some of the modern is sinking we want
our seats to be were bein we want to
make good or beneath the strongest
selling point in our project this this
sculpture is a famous sculpture in
brazil done by bruno giorgio it's called
can dangle can language is sort of
depreciated name for the work that came
to work in Brasilia nowadays everybody
second angry Brasilia it's kind of what
to call the guys at born in Brasilia and
but at an empty honor the sculpture
because Brasilia was not done for them
they were the excluded part of Brazil
despite all the talk about the equality
equality and all that that Lucy had some
we are all equals but some are more
equal than others my dream at that
someday the content goes we'll be able
to walk on the streets bike to work city
is it in a park and enjoy the sun or in
a sidewalk cafe and watch people coming
and enjoy enjoy life that's the the
dream I have for them and that
experience none of them has today to sum
up my walk I want to say that it was a
walk from side to city in search of a
new urban ethics and I thank us as
developers I've not talked about actors
but just as developers we need to find a
new ethics how to deal and how to look
to our cities the challenge represent to
Sunil in our studio is to design this
environment at the urban environment to
create a city in closing I'd like to
apologize to Dean roberts10 a few months
ago I asked him about what should I
speak he said stick to what you know and
as you saw I went way beyond that he
also said I want you to bring reality to
two students the business reality to the
students and I only brought dreams and
fantasies but I'm afraid that's why I
could do so Jeanne Stern my sincerest
apologies and thank you for having me
thank you soo new for your help and
thank you for your patience
the nice thing about being a Dean is
nobody ever pays any attention to you
but that is good thank you for a
wonderful talk would you take questions
absolutely yes I think Jim must be a
photo about the answers but the
questions like well developers never
lack for answers are there questions for
Raphael Biermann down here please we
need a mic thank you very much you
talked a fair bit about ideas coming
from Europe and North America to Brazil
do you see much in the way of export of
urbanistic ideas from Brazil to us for
instance I think we in Brazil was just
talking about that over lunch we are big
country and they may be because of that
we close ourselves we don't like much
importation we don't like foreign actors
and that reduces our ability to grow and
to develop a good strong architecture I
don't think we have a stronger cater
today I have I think we I know we have
great talent in the country but I think
they've been hammered and and push it
down by by the ghost of that lives until
a couple years ago Oscar Niemeyer so and
I don't know very few are as I know that
from the Soviet went abroad frankly I i
don't i'm not very hopefully on that i
don't see much they aren't clear
wait wait wait on the mic choosing that
such a critique of niemeyer should come
from you but it's so interesting that
Niemeyer's own house in Brasilia is
traditionally designed finger with Roman
tiles you know it it's in the book of
all these houses is I could have
designed but would be interesting to see
how why he did that because in his own
tongue I think in the end he was a smart
guy other questions comments well then I
think we'll thank our speaker again and
join him in the gallery
you